Cześć, mam na imię Olivia Lan i jestem badaczką i edukatorką w IBM Quantum. Ten film wyznacza premierę
zupełnie nowej serii na kanale YouTube Qiskit i naszej platformie edukacyjnej, zatytułowanej „Obliczenia kwantowe
w praktyce". Krótko mówiąc, w tej serii pokażę ci, jak używać komputera kwantowego istniejącego teraz, w pełni
wykorzystując jego potencjał. W internecie są już miliardy filmów o komputerach kwantowych i ich przyszłym potencjale, lub o teoretycznych koncepcjach
leżących u podstaw obliczeń kwantowych, które są równie ważne – patrz „Understanding Quantum Information and Computation"
prowadzone przez Johna Watrousa na przykład. Ale w tym kursie założymy, że uczący się wie może trochę więcej
niż w przeszłości i zajdziemy bardzo daleko pod względem technicznym. A to dlatego, że przez ostatni rok i w
momencie tego nagrania jest rok 2024, widzimy zmianę – przejście fazowe, jeśli wolisz – do nowej ery
obliczeń. Komputery kwantowe w końcu zbliżają się do punktu, w którym mogą być użyteczne. Choć eksperymentowanie z
małoskalowymi circuits i komputerami kwantowymi było konieczne, żeby edukowali naszą społeczność jak korzystać z tych maszyn, nikt nie uruchamiał eksperymentów,
których nie można też wykonać na zwykłych klasycznych komputerach. Ale od dziś weszliśmy w erę
kwantowej użyteczności. Czym jest użyteczność, możesz zapytać? Różni się od kwantowej przewagi, którą można rozumieć jako
punkt, w którym komputery kwantowe przewyższają klasyczne przy sensownym zadaniu. Użyteczność natomiast oznacza,
że zaczyna się z nimi konkurować, i to jest naturalny kolejny krok w technologicznej
ewolucji. IBM opublikowało artykuł, który pokazał po raz pierwszy w zeszłym roku, że komputer kwantowy może być użyty do
symulacji modelu fizycznego i konkurować z najnowocześniejszymi technikami klasycznej symulacji. Nawet prześcignął
próby brute force i dał badaczom nową ścieżkę, którą mogą używać do badań. Dlaczego to wszystko dzieje się
teraz? W ciągu ostatnich kilku miesięcy IBM udostępnił szerzej procesory kwantowe o ponad 100 qubitach. Jeśli
jesteś już użytkownikiem, mogłeś zauważyć, że zdjęliśmy wiele naszych mniejszych procesorów, żeby zrobić miejsce na te większe chipy, i uznaliśmy, że to naprawdę
ważne, żeby to zrobić, bo pewne liczby qubitów wciąż można symulować klasycznie bez problemu, więc nie ma
żadnej prawdziwej przewagi z używania tych chipów. Jednak przy 100 qubitach to już nie jest przypadek – nie można
ich symulować klasycznie. Ważne jest też odnotowanie, że istnieją te rzeczy zwane symulatorami, które
są zasadniczo programami komputerowymi i mogą naśladować pewne zachowanie systemów kwantowych, w tym szum. Jednak proszę
nie przegap faktu, że powiedziałam „naśladować" – symulatory nie są komputerami kwantowymi. Nie mogą produkować wyników, które
komputery kwantowe mogą w tej skali. Ale są wciąż ważną częścią naszego przepływu pracy testowej. Więc to była bardzo
obszerna odpowiedź na pytanie na początku tego slajdu: czym są praktyczne obliczenia kwantowe? W tym kursie nauczę cię o realistycznych
potencjalnych przypadkach użycia dla kwantowych i najlepszych praktykach uruchamiania i eksperymentowania na tych procesorach w większej skali
dzisiaj. Więc do kogo jest skierowany ten kurs? Zacznijmy od ustalenia poziomu
na początku. Ten kurs jest dla wszystkich, którzy chcą rozwijać nowe aplikacje dla komputerów kwantowych, chcą
wiedzieć, jak skalować swoją obecną pracę lub nauczyć się, jak używać kwantowych w swoich istniejących przepływach pracy. Wcześniej
wspomniałam, że ten kurs będzie bardzo praktyczny i nie będziemy omawiać aspektów teoretycznych prawie w ogóle. Oczekujemy,
że przychodzisz z podstawowym zrozumieniem czym jest obliczenie kwantowe, ale jeśli jeszcze do tego nie dotarłeś, nie martw się – po prostu obejrzyj
pierwsze kilka odcinków kursu Johna Watrusa i będziesz gotowy. Chcemy się też upewnić, że ludzie oglądający wiedzą,
że to nie jest tylko kurs dla fizyków czy nawet informatyków. Te dwie dziedziny naprawdę
monopolizowały obliczenia kwantowe przez ostatnią dekadę. Chcemy się upewnić, że inni, którzy pracują z dużymi danymi lub
symulacjami, jak inżynierowie, chemicy i naukowcy materiałowi, wiedzą, że ten kurs jest też dla nich. W skrócie,
kurs jest skierowany do szerokiego odbiorcy i mamy nadzieję, że dołączysz do nas na całość. Po ukończeniu tego kursu
będziesz mógł zrozumieć, jak tworzyć i uruchamiać zadanie w skali użyteczności przez Qiskit Runtime, w tym cały przepływ pracy.
Będziesz mógł zrozumieć główne typy mitygacji błędów, a także zrozumieć prawdopodobne obszary zastosowań w krótkim terminie. Będziesz też mógł
wykonywać wszystkie te algorytmy w Qiskit i na koniec oczekujemy, że będziesz mógł zrozumieć szum i jak sobie z nim radzić.
Zacznijmy więc. Obliczenia kwantowe to ekscytująca nowa technologia we wczesnym stadium rozwoju, ale to tylko
jeden rozdział w historii obliczeń, która sięga tysięcy lat wstecz. Myślę, że ważne jest rozumienie tego
kontekstu, bo sprawia, że to, co staramy się tu zrobić, jest nieco bardziej intuicyjne, przewidywalne i mniej
science-fiction. Od starożytności my jako ludzie musieliśmy wykonywać obliczenia, lub
innymi słowy, przetwarzać informacje według pewnych reguł i ograniczeń, żeby umożliwiać
komunikację, budownictwo, handel, naukę i wszystkie inne aspekty naszego życia. Szukaliśmy pomocy w świecie fizycznym
i przez genialne odkrycia budowaliśmy urządzenia, które pomagały nam obliczać. Dawno temu urządzenia były
zrobione z drewna, kości, zawiązanych sznurów i przechowywały informacje oraz ułatwiały obliczenia znacznie inaczej niż robimy to
dzisiaj. Urządzenia mechaniczne zbudowane z dźwigni, kół zębatych i innej maszynerii rozwijały się od wczesnych zegarów astronomicznych do
kalkulatorów, po zaawansowane urządzenia obliczeniowe, jak analizatory różnicowe, które rozwiązywały równania za pomocą kół i
obracających się krążków. Nawet technologia pisma odegrała ważną rolę w tej historii, pozwalając ludziom wykonywać
obliczenia, których inaczej nie byliby w stanie. Kiedy myślimy o komputerach dzisiaj, mamy tendencję do myślenia o
elektronicznych komputerach cyfrowych, ale to jest w rzeczywistości dość świeża technologia. Elektroniczne komputery cyfrowe
zostały zbudowane po raz pierwszy w latach 40. XX wieku. Najwcześniejsze znane narzędzie do obliczania to właściwie sumeryjski abakus,
który zdaniem ekspertów został wynaleziony w Babilonie w 2700 do 2300 p.n.e. To jest naprawdę
bardzo dawno temu. Ale coraz lepiej rozumiemy świat naturalny – od Archimedesa przez Eulera po
Einsteina – i nasze zapotrzebowanie na więcej zasobów obliczeniowych gwałtownie wzrosło. Dziś mamy superkomputery, które są
zasadniczo wieloma bardzo potężnymi komputerami podłączonymi równolegle. Są jednym z najlepszych narzędzi ludzkości do
rozwiązywania trudnych problemów, ale wciąż istnieje mnóstwo problemów, których nawet te wielkie komputery nigdy nie będą w stanie
rozwiązać. Więcej na ten temat później. Więc ustaliliśmy, że ludzie używają fizyki i natury, żeby pomóc nam obliczać
od tysięcy lat i pomagać nam w niekończącym się dążeniu do obliczania coraz więcej i coraz większych rzeczy. Możesz już
WEBVTT
znać Prawo Moore'a – właściwie to nie jest prawo, a bardziej obserwacja, ta część z „prawem" jest moim zdaniem nieco
ironiczna. Maksymalna liczba tranzystorów w układzie scalonym – zasadniczo chipie komputerowym –
podwaja się mniej więcej co dwa lata. Przez ostatnie pięć dekad nie tylko to obserwowaliśmy, ale też świetnie
z tego korzystaliśmy. Dzięki większej liczbie tranzystorów możemy wykonywać więcej szybszych obliczeń. To zasadniczo jest odpowiedzialne za
to, że komputery stawały się coraz mocniejsze i mniejsze z biegiem czasu. Są jednak złe wiadomości – Prawo Moore'a umiera.
Eksperci nie zgadzają się co do tego, kiedy Prawo Moore'a dojdzie do swojego końca, ale niektórzy mówią, że już tak się stało. Choć nie możemy
być pewni dokładnie kiedy osiągniemy nasz limit, wiemy, że jest to w końcu nieuchronne, bo niektóre części tranzystorów
nie mogą być fizycznie mniejsze. Nie możesz zrobić tranzystora mniejszego niż atom, na przykład. To jest
oczywiście zupełnie niefizykalne – brzmi absurdalnie, ale to są limity, z którymi faktycznie pracujemy. Więc co
zrobimy – po prostu poddamy się i powiemy, że to tyle, ile możemy osiągnąć? Nie, ludzie nigdy tego nie robili. Na szczęście mechanika kwantowa
weszła do rozmowy. Mechanika kwantowa została odkryta w latach 20. XX wieku i od tamtego czasu świat
dosłownie nigdy nie był już taki sam. Moglibyśmy spędzić godziny mówiąc o rewolucjonizujących odkryciach, które zostały
dokonane, ale to nie jest główny temat tego kursu. Chcę zamiast tego jasno pokazać, że wiemy, że mechanika kwantowa
i obliczenia są już ze sobą kompatybilne. Odkrycia i zrozumienia natury, których nauczyliśmy się z mechaniki kwantowej,
częściowo umożliwiły nasze współczesne komputery. Bez mechaniki kwantowej nie rozumielibyśmy ani prawdopodobnie
nie bylibyśmy w stanie wynaleźć dysku twardego SSD, na przykład. Obliczenia kwantowe to po prostu naturalny kolejny
krok w tej ewolucji. Ale obliczenia nie istnieją w próżni – informacja wymaga nośnika.
Przetwarzanie informacji wykorzystuje świat fizyczny i na niego wpływa. Nakłada to ograniczenia na to, co jest w ogóle
fizycznie możliwe. Ale rozumienie natury i fizycznych ograniczeń jest właśnie celem fizyki jako
dyscypliny. Więc w pewnym sensie fizyka i obliczenia zawsze były ze sobą splecione. Ralph Landauer, informatyk i pracownik
IBM, uznał dziesiątki lat temu, że informacja jest fizyczna. Innymi słowy, informacja nie jest
abstrakcyjnym bytem, ale istnieje tylko przez fizyczną reprezentację. Zasada Landauera ustanawia połączenie
między informacją a prawami termodynamiki. Ale faktycznie jest wiele powiązań między fizyką
a obliczeniami. Klasyczna fizyka była wszystkim, co mogliśmy badać do niedawna, ale z odkryciem mechaniki kwantowej
jesteśmy teraz na progu stworzenia zupełnie nowego sposobu obliczania. I to jest świetne, bo
komputery klasyczne mogą tylko przybliżać to, co faktycznie zachodzi w naturze, i w niektórych przypadkach to przybliżenie jest bardzo
ograniczone. Dzieje się tak, bo naprawdę trudno jest sprawić, żeby maszyny podlegające prawom klasycznej fizyki
przybliżały prawa fizyki kwantowej – a natura nie jest klasyczna, jest kwantowa. Analogia, która może ci pomóc
zrozumieć, to tunel aerodynamiczny. Dynamika płynów jest notoryczne trudna do symulowania i matematycznego przewidywania.
Nawet coś tak przyziemnego jak samochód jadący przez wiatr – producenci samochodów odkryli, że było to faktycznie
zbyt kosztowne i niepraktyczne, żeby próbować symulować tę fizyczną interakcję przy projektowaniu samochodów. Zamiast tego, co
zrobili, to stworzyli dosłowny tunel, który przez niego dmie, i po prostu wjechali samochodem w tunel
i zobaczyli, jak działa. Jest to analogiczne do tego, co mam na myśli mówiąc, że komputery klasyczne jedynie słabo
przybliżają naturę i czasem zbyt kosztowne jest nawet próbowanie. Zamiast symulować wiatr,
badacze po prostu go odtwarzają. Podobnie, komputery kwantowe nie muszą przybliżać praw natury na
poziomie molekularnym, bo je z natury podlegają tym prawom. Nie muszą nic symulować – emulują je. I
te same trudności pojawiają się przy symulowaniu baterii lub reakcji chemicznych, co prowadzi nas do następnej
sekcji: obliczenia kwantowe – do czego się nadają?
Więc dlaczego w ogóle chcielibyśmy łączyć mechanikę kwantową i obliczenia? Cóż, istnieje już mnóstwo
problemów, które są zbyt trudne, zbyt kosztowne obliczeniowo nawet dla naszych najnowocześniejszych superkomputerów.
Może są to problemy, na których skupiają się tylko badacze, ale ich wpływ mógłby dotknąć wszystkich zakątków
globu. Te problemy, przy których komputery klasyczne się zatykają, to rzeczy, na których jako społeczeństwo coraz bardziej
polegamy na technologii i naprawdę nam na nich zależy – jak efektywność baterii, modelowanie finansowe i
optymalizacja, a nawet jak budować lepsze samoloty. Dlaczego więc zwrócić się do komputerów kwantowych? Mamy bardzo dobre powody,
żeby myśleć, że jest tu duży potencjał i że możemy otworzyć drzwi do nowych obliczeń, które są obecnie poza zasięgiem nawet
najpotężniejszych superkomputerów. W teorii, niektóre algorytmy kwantowe zapewniają przewagę nad
najlepszymi możliwymi algorytmami klasycznymi w niektórych zastosowaniach. W innych zastosowaniach istnieją coraz mocniejsze dowody na to, że nawet
z pewnym szumem i niedoskonałościami komputery kwantowe mogą być używane jako narzędzie do rywalizacji z klasycznymi rozwiązaniami brute
force. W zasadzie to zupełnie nowe narzędzie i chcemy odkrywać jeszcze więcej fajnych rzeczy, które możemy z nim zrobić. Możemy też
spojrzeć na oryginalny pomysł Feynmana dla nich, którym jest używanie ich do rozumienia samej fizyki i natury.
W końcu już powiedziałam, że natura jest kwantowa, nie klasyczna, a ta dziedzina jest niesamowicie bogata, fascynująca i
interdyscyplinarna. Łączy fizykę, informatykę, przetwarzanie informacji i oczywiście konkretne domeny obszarów zastosowań, które
mogą nas interesować. Jednak w przeciwieństwie do komputerów klasycznych, nie każdy ma komputer kwantowy schowany w tylnej
kieszeni. Do niedawna, jeśli chciałeś eksperymentować z komputerem kwantowym, musiałeś go zbudować i utrzymywać
samodzielnie, zazwyczaj w smutnym piwnicy laboratorium na uniwersytecie lub obiekcie badawczym. I uwierz mi, wiem, o czym mówię. To już nie
jest jednak przypadek. W 2016 roku IBM umieścił pierwszy procesor kwantowy w chmurze. Miał wtedy tylko pięć qubitów i
dość wysoki wskaźnik błędów, ale to było zaledwie 8 lat temu i spójrz, jak daleko zaszliśmy. Więc gdzie jesteśmy dzisiaj?
Jest wiele analogii do bardzo wczesnych dni współczesnych komputerów. Jak wspomniałam, to jest bardzo
trudne wyzwanie i dopiero w ciągu ostatnich 8 lat komputery kwantowe stały się powszechnie dostępne – poza
tymi, którzy pracowali w laboratorium lub obiekcie na czołowym froncie. Ale przez te ostatnie osiem lat zrobiliśmy postęp na każdym
froncie – procesory są o rzędy wielkości większe pod względem liczby qubitów, bramki są znacznie ulepszone i wprowadziliśmy metody
WEBVTT
na każdym froncie. Procesory są o rzędy wielkości większe pod względem liczby qubitów, bramki są znacznie ulepszone i wprowadziliśmy metody
redukcji lub mitygacji błędów wewnętrznych w systemach kwantowych, nawet gdy zmierzamy do stworzenia odpornych na błędy
komputerów kwantowych. Teraz ty i każdy inny możecie korzystać z wielu procesorów kwantowych IBM
hostowanych w chmurze – prawie wszystkich będących najnowszymi, najlepszymi systemami z ponad 100
qubitami. Ale sama wielkość procesorów nie jest tym, co ważne – to tylko jedna metryka, o którą dbamy. I
to ma sens, prawda? Jeśli mamy więcej qubitów, to oczywiście lepiej, pod warunkiem, że zwiększanie liczby qubitów
nie pogarsza wydajności. Jednak tak nie jest zawsze. Potrzebujemy więcej dobrej jakości qubitów, które nie interferują
ze sobą przez przesłuch, gdy nie chcemy, żeby to robiły. To, jak qubity są ze sobą połączone, jest też ważne do wzięcia pod uwagę. W
nadprzewodzących circuits to wyzwanie, żeby wymyślić, jak najlepiej fizycznie połączyć qubity. Inną niezwykle ważną metryką
jest wierność bramki dwuqubitowej. Bramki działające na pojedynczych qubitach nie są tak podatne na błędy. Bramki dwuqubitowe to
znacznie większy obszar troski i zazwyczaj jedna z głównych metryk, które sprawdzamy, żeby zobaczyć, jak wydajność poprawia się w czasie.
Bramki dwuqubitowe są kluczowe do prawidłowego działania, bo są odpowiedzialne za tworzenie splątania między qubitami,
co jest jednym z zjawisk fizycznych, które nadają komputerom kwantowym ich moc. I na koniec patrzymy na szybkość i wydajność.
Musimy upewnić się, że czas spędzony na uruchamianiu programu na chipie kwantowym jest wykonywany jak najszybciej i jak najwydajniej.
Określamy te trzy metryki razem jako skalę, jakość i
szybkość – wszystkie są istotne do poprawy wydajności. Teraz chcę pokazać ci kilka szybkich wykresów, żeby poprzeć to, co mówiłam
o tym, że sama technologia naprawdę szybko się rozwija. Liczba qubitów jest chyba najłatwiejsza do
zrozumienia, a IBM opublikowało mapę drogową tego, gdzie mamy nadzieję być w ciągu najbliższych kilku lat pod względem liczby qubitów
i rozmiaru procesorów. Na rok 2024, gdy kręcimy ten film, jesteśmy dokładnie na torze z naszym procesorem Heron i Condor. Następnie
jakość – ten wykres pokazuje medianę wskaźnika błędu bramki splątującej dla procesorów IBM Quantum w czasie. Pamiętaj,
że to jest skala logarytmyczna, więc chociaż postęp wygląda mgliście liniowo, jest faktycznie znacznie szybszy niż to.
I na koniec mamy szybkość – ten wykres pokazuje postęp metryki, którą nazywamy CLOPS, co oznacza circuit layer
operations per second. Co istotne, CLOPS obejmuje zarówno czas potrzebny do uruchamiania circuits, jak i wymagane obliczenia klasyczne w czasie
rzeczywistym i quasi-rzeczywistym. Zasadniczo CLOPS jest miarą tego, jak szybko nasze procesory mogą uruchamiać konkretne circuits w
serii, służąc jako miara holistycznej szybkości systemu i uwzględniając kwantowe i klasyczne
obliczenia. Teraz, w momencie nagrywania, IBM jest jedynym dostawcą chmury kwantowej, który zapewnia dostęp do maszyn
z 100+ qubitami. Jak wspomniałam kilka slajdów temu, 100 qubitów lub gdzieś w okolicach tego to gdzie klasyczna symulacja
zaczyna całkowicie zawodzić. Więc zadania na dużą skalę uruchamiane na tych maszynach często nie mają klasycznego odpowiednika – jest to
niemożliwe. Jest pewna niuansowość i pewne triki, które możesz zagrać, żeby symulować niektóre części circuit, a potem inne
części osobno, ale ogólnie wiemy, że gdzieś w okolicach tej liczby jest to, gdzie komputery kwantowe mogą zacząć robić rzeczy, których komputery klasyczne po prostu nie mogą. Więc
IBM postanowił, że dawanie dostępu do tych większych urządzeń jest super ważne dla szerszej społeczności, bo cokolwiek
robione na mniejszych urządzeniach jest klasycznie symulowalne i nie może prowadzić do kwantowej przewagi. Urządzenia 100-qubitowe,
które mamy teraz, są wciąż wadliwe i hałaśliwe, więc musimy być sprytni w tym, jak uruchamiamy zadania i
circuits na nich. Naiwne napisanie naszego circuit i naciśnięcie shift+enter prawdopodobnie nie prowadzi do niczego
spektakularnego. Ale znowu, są triki i najlepsze praktyki, które możemy wdrożyć i stosować, żeby wycisnąć jeszcze
więcej wydajności z tych urządzeń, co mamy nadzieję prowadzić do kwantowej przewagi szybciej, nawet gdy kontynuujemy
pracę i budowanie naszych odpornych na błędy maszyn. Ten wykres pokazuje koszt symulacji
czyli czas potrzebny do rozwiązania problemu na komputerach klasycznych i komputerach kwantowych wyposażonych w mitygację błędów
i korekcję błędów. Więc linia klasycznych obliczeń skaluje się wykładniczo wraz ze wzrostem złożoności circuit.
Dla prostych circuits tu na dole to nie ma znaczenia, ale jest oczywiście złe przy rosnącej złożoności, bo sprawia to, że
koszt symulacji staje się bardzo drogi bardzo szybko. Mitygacja błędów skaluje się lepiej, więc gdy złożoność
circuit rośnie, tu chcemy być. Obecnie jesteśmy tu z metodami klasycznymi i kwantowymi mniej więcej na
równi w niektórych zastosowaniach, a korekcja błędów może być najbardziej preferowana i ładnie skaluje się –
jeszcze tam nie jesteśmy. W międzyczasie będziemy nadal koncentrować się na mitygacji błędów i dotarciu do tego
obszaru kwantowej użyteczności jak najszybciej. I stosując kilka schematów mitygacji błędów, o których
dowiemy się w tej serii, dążymy do znalezienia obszarów zastosowań, które mogą korzystać z kwantowej użyteczności bardzo wkrótce. I to jest
naprawdę sedno tego kursu – mamy te maszyny, uważamy, że są zdolne do wykonania naprawdę interesujących
badań, więc jak ich używamy? W tej ostatniej sekcji odcinka omówmy pokrótce obszary zastosowań dla
praktycznych obliczeń kwantowych. Są trzy główne gałęzie, które według nas najbardziej ekscytują nas do zbadania i znalezienia ścieżek dla kwantowej
użyteczności. Pierwsza to symulowanie natury – dotyczy symulowania oddziaływań molekularnych lub atomowych i jest
naprawdę ważna dla obszarów nauki o materiałach i chemii. Z powodów, które omówiliśmy wcześniej, uważamy, że komputery kwantowe
będą o wiele lepsze w tym niż ich klasyczne odpowiedniki. Następnie jest wyszukiwanie i
optymalizacja. Główny algorytm zainteresowania tutaj to QAOA – hybrydyczny klasyczno-kwantowy algorytm. QAOA używa
klasycznego komputera do trenowania i znajdowania optymalnych parametrów dla quantum circuit i mamy nadzieję, że będziemy w stanie to robić
znacznie wydajniej niż każdy komputer osobno. I na koniec mamy matematykę i przetwarzanie danych ze strukturą. Komputery kwantowe
są naprawdę dobre w znajdowaniu struktury w chaotycznych danych, gdzie ty, ja czy typowy komputer możemy nic nie
zauważyć. Kwantowe uczenie maszynowe obiecuje w tym obszarze i dążymy do używania go do zadań takich jak ekstrakcja cech
i rozpoznawanie wzorców. To naprawdę bardzo ekscytujący czas dla tych z nas, którzy pracują w
dziedzinie obliczeń kwantowych. Po raz pierwszy w historii możemy zacząć eksplorować region obliczeń wykraczający poza
obliczenia klasyczne. Ci z was oglądający to mogą możliwe, że odegrają rolę podobną do wczesnych pionierów
obliczeń – i nie mieli oni pojęcia, co miało nastąpić. T. J. Watson z IBM nawet słynnie powiedział, że myślał, że będzie rynek
WEBVTT
tylko na dwa lub trzy komputery w ogóle, i jakże się mylił. My
wszyscy jesteśmy tymi wczesnymi pionierami obliczeń, ale w tej nowej dziedzinie obliczeń kwantowych. Kwantowe jest często
kontrastowane z klasycznym jako coś wyraźnie innego i często z nim konkurującego. Ale moim
celem w tym wykładzie wprowadzającym było, mam nadzieję, przekonanie cię, że z lotu ptaka możemy postrzegać obliczenia kwantowe
jako po prostu kolejny rozdział w długiej historii obliczeń. Jest to w naszej naturze jako ludzi szukanie nowych sposobów
obliczania i wykorzystywania mocy świata naturalnego oraz wymyślania, co z tym zrobić. Robimy to
od stuleci. Obliczenia kwantowe oferują nam nowe narzędzie w tym dążeniu i to od nas zależy, jak możemy wykorzystać
moc, którą nam oferują. W następnej lekcji z serii porozmawiamy trochę więcej o układach 100-qubitowych
i damy przegląd Qiskit – naszego SDK oprogramowania kwantowego – i jak najlepiej teraz współpracować z tymi maszynami. Dzięki za
oglądanie i do zobaczenia następnym razem.